señor vamos a quienes representa el
grupo al que ustedes pertenecen
nosotros somos una agrupación de
ciudadanos que va desde los sectores
académicos sindicales gremiales
organizaciones y partidos políticos que
hemos decidido formular la propuesta de
activación del reto
en el espíritu de poder animar a que el
resto de los sectores políticos y
sociales puedan sumarse a esta
convocatoria que estamos haciendo en el
cumplimiento de la serie de activos
tenemos a gente desde las bases del
partido comunista hasta la gente de 20
venezuela de maría corina machado en una
gama de expresiones
importantes